[Music]
as we mark 20 years since the deadliest
terror attack on u.s soil we want to pay
tribute to the heroes who ran into
danger to help so many others escape
343 new york city firefighters died on
september 11th and that does not include
the more than 250 who have since died
from illnesses related to the attack
this morning we are sharing the story of
one of new york city's bravest and his
sons who are carrying on the legacy
it's 8 52 here in new york i'm brian
gumbel we understand that there has been
a plane crash on the southern tip of
manhattan 20 years ago this week oh my
god another plane has just hit it hit
another building after the worst terror
attack in american history
the best of america rushed in to help
and that's what the guys are taught joe
and chuck downey knew their father ray
downey would be among them did a part of
you hope maybe there's a chance your
father wasn't there in the mix
yeah
i said even if he was home he would have
been heading in he would have been there
no matter what yeah
sure enough a film crew happened to
capture deputy chief downey that morning
coordinating rescues in the lobby of the
north tower
[Applause]
raymond matthew downey senior knew the
dangers that day perhaps better than
anyone hello my name is ray downey
senior he developed training programs as
a pioneer in the field of so-called
technical rescue meaning he was an
expert in pulling people from collapsed
buildings he went to every major
disaster in the city pretty much in the
country at that time
after a truck bomb leveled the federal
building in oklahoma city in 1995 downey
led the search for survivors and when it
came to saving lives he had a nickname
as big as his reputation someone said oh
yeah
he's sitting next to god on the way in
i'm like who's god
he said oh yeah they refer to your dad
that way sometimes
i'm like well that's pretty impressive
yeah they just saw how he operated fires
and conducted himself
at emergencies and he just was always in
charge so the downey brothers knew where
their father would be that day he parked
right here on west street because that's
where we found his car and they knew he
wouldn't leave no matter what he has
that mentality he wasn't leaving until
he could save as many people as possible
even as the towers burned above him
even as he knew exactly what could
happen
were you angry when you found out he
wasn't coming home
maybe a little angry at first but then
as it went on more proud
that
you can give your life that you talk
about all the time
and not many people do that
consciously give their life
all this and he did it that day and i
think it's just fitting
who he was and the person that he was
that he would do that
ray downey is buried on new york's long
island not far from where his children
grew up in a home now lined with
tributes and awards i haven't seen these
in a long time a flip through some
family photos reveals some of the risks
he faced every day oh wow oh [ __ ] yeah
coming out of a fire
yes like he's sweating and some you know
he didn't really use his mask much
trying to breathe so you may wonder as
we did how his wife rosalie feels about
two of her sons following in rey's
footsteps very proud
i couldn't feel more proud
and i tell him all the time your father
is really smiling up there i know it
chuck downey is now a deputy chief like
his father and joe a battalion chief
works in his dad's old firehouse this is
your father up here on the left yes
where ray still has a presence you
always refer back to ray downey you
really do but 20 years later the downey
brothers worry the rest of us might
still need a reminder of the sacrifices
made by their father and the
342 other firefighters who went into
those buildings that day
and never came out it's easy to forget
everybody says we're never going to
forget they use that term but a lot of
people do forget and i'm not faulting
them if they're not personally connected
you could forget yeah so just that alone
is i think part of the reason that we
want to give back and carry his name and
i think that goes in every five house
guys we're friends with people that pass
and they want to keep that person's
legacy alive because of their sacrifices
and chuck and joe downey are keeping
that legacy alive their father is a very
definition of valor we ran into the
former commissioner of the fire
department at ground zero uh tom van
essen who told us that on 9 11
ray downey actually found him in the
lobby of one of the towers before they
fell and he said to him you know boss
these towers can come down
which lets you know that he was
conscious of the risk he knew and the
rescue situation was active thousands
were coming out people were being saved
he knew he was in danger and they stayed
him and everyone else and that is the
very definition of a hero i'm so
impressed with his sons too to go that
journey from anger to pride and i can't
imagine what it was like seeing your
dad's car knowing that you're not going
to see your dad again but it's beautiful
too to see his picture in the firehouse
yeah so it's the sun you get to see the
legacy lives on forever it is the
biggest sacrifice you can make your life
to save somebody else yes